welcome
everyone um is to the
first seminar for the spring 2021
um so we have the pleasure of having
thomas ginn today from the center for
global development and he will be
presenting the paper on prisoner
sanctuary and evaluation of camps for
syrian refugees
so thomas he's a part of
the migration displacement and
humanitarian policy
team at the cgd and
his current research asked how to design
policy and allocate assistance to
benefit
refugees and host communities alike
his research on the middle east examines
the trade-off
of camps and opening schools to refugees
and in randomized controlled trials in
east africa he's studying how
livelihoods programs can improve both
economic outcomes and social cohesion
as a principal investigator of the let
them work initiative he's studying how
refugees
labor market access affect host
communities
attitudes and levels of humanitarian
assistance
prior to joining cgd dr gang work at the
war bank on a survey of syrian refugees
in lebanon
jordan and iraqi kurdistan and with the
innovation for providing the action in
kenya
he received his phd in economics from
stanford university and his bachelor
degree from the university of north
carolina at
chapel hill so just before passing to
him
let me just remind you that
we are recording as you are aware this
seminar if you have declined
uh to accept the yell policy on
recording material
please make sure that you have your
camera turn off
and um you cannot ask
questions live but if you if you send
them through the chat we'll make sure
to to ask them so there you go so thomas
uh please great teresa thank you so much
thank you
uh to you tarana to mushvik for inviting
me and for
organizing this uh and thank you to
everyone for coming today i'm excited to
be here
uh so before i get started um you
please interrupt me with questions uh at
any time so we can just do this like a
uh econ seminar uh just to interrupt me
whenever questions come up or to put
them in the chat
great so my name is thomas gan i'm a
research fellow at the center for global
development and i'll be talking today
about
camps for syrian refugees
because i'm sure this audience is is
aware about 80 million people are
displaced by conflict
worldwide and at least 10 million of
these displaced people live
in official camps or settlements that
are managed by
uh usually the u.n so the alternative
that i want you to think about in this
talk is that otherwise
uh displaced people they're still
displaced but they live in towns cities
informal settlements uh they self-settle
and have to find their own
find and pay for their own accommodation
and consistent with the humanitarian
dialogue i'm going to call all of these
people urban even though a few of them
live in rural areas
so some of the reasons that camps exist
oftentimes these are negotiations
between
the host governments and the
international community
the main argument being that host
governments want to isolate refugees in
order to
minimize crowd out in terms of the labor
market in terms of public services
in terms of uh the housing market
and so as a way to to keep uh refugees
isolated from the host communities
in non-profits humanitarians also find
this efficient
to identify and to distribute the most
vulnerable for
short-run assistance but critics of
camps
uh rightly note that it's makes it much
easier to impose serious restrictions on
movements violating the
convention uh for refugees and human
rights
uh for for refugees who are in camp and
also as displacement is such a long run
event in many cases
the worry is that camps will prevent
long-run self-reliance
for refugees who are in camp so given
these criticisms in 2014 the un
high commission for refugees unhcr
announced a policy change
that camps would now be the exception
only a temporary measure
after a history of only kind of serving
refugees
who were in camps so the question that i
want to look at here is
think about what are the effects of
creating a camp on well-being
and i'm going to talk mostly today about
uh the effects on
camp residents because i think that's
where we have uh the least amount of
data
for now but i'm also going to then
extend this and think about
the effects of creating a camp on urban
refugees
and on host citizens at the end
there we go so the setting that i'm
going to look at is the largest
displacement setting in the world right
now that's
syrians i'm going to be looking at
mostly in syrian refugees in jordan
and the northern region of iraq the
kurdistan region
and so here we're looking at the zaatari
camp a
population of about 80 000 people in
northern jordan
and to illustrate some of the criticisms
from
uh of camps the affordable housing
institute's 2014 report starts out that
if the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
then the newest slums autry and jordan
is a four lane highway there
and so i went into this project
expecting to find
negative effects i thought it was
important to add measurement to this
uh this policy discussion with new data
that i helped to collect
and i've spent time in these camps and
it's obvious that life is very difficult
and boring but when i started the data
it's also
it's not easy to form perceptions on the
alternative because most urban refugees
are less visible to
non-profits into journalists and i think
we want to assume that they're doing
better and i think that's where rigorous
data collection is so important and in
this case
kind of led to some surprising findings
for me
so the research questions that i'm
interested in here how does living in a
camp
instead of the local community affect a
variety of outcomes
i'm going to start out with labor market
labor market outcomes
like wages and employment and then
crucially look at this income relative
to the cost of living so refugees in
camps don't pay any rent and that's
going to become
an important part of my story here
then of course i'm going to look at all
the other factors that we have data on
that that inform places about how
satisfied we are with the places we live
things about access to education to
health care your social networks
perceptions of safety and then the
respondents were asked about an overall
measure of satisfaction to kind of
weight these criteria as they see fit
then we want to look at how does this
difference across locations evolve over
time
so in this case refugees have been
displaced when we collected
these data for on average about three
years so that's not
speaking to the long run effects that
we're most concerned about but at least
gives us
some extent and i'll try to bolster this
with a few more recent surveys
of my findings here then uh another kind
of big picture way to look at this is
i'm trying to think about whether camps
are cost effective so would camp
residents prefer
the additional aid expenses camps are
more expensive would they prefer that
additional
aid in cash and whether camps and jordan
are generating what economists call a
deadweight loss
or a potential efficiency gain by these
humanitarians from opening
the data that i'm going to use we
collected in 2015 and 2016 across
lebanon the iraqi uh kurdistan region in
northern iraq
and in northern jordan now i'm going to
present the estimates from jordan first
because i have
cost estimates from both the government
and humanitarian organizations on how
much they're
spending on refugees disaggregated by
location
in order to complete the picture around
cost effectiveness
there's also a larger literature on the
effects of urban refugees on jordanians
so in order to
contribute to that discussion i'm also
going to uh to start with jordan
just to give a very brief setting of the
context so 18
of refugees here are choosing and i
intentionally put that in quotation
marks because
some are have more of a choice uh
than others for sure given that the
restrictions and how they've evolved
uh to live in camps and it's important
also to note here that
contrary to many many other settings the
direct aid
in uh in jordan was similar for
urban and camp refugees so that's going
to be one setting that i'm going to find
these initial results and
i'm going to extend to iraqi kurdistan
where there's a different
paradigm for hosting refugees and see if
the results hold there and
the story is remarkably similar and so
these data we collected in 2016 and i
we asked people to recall their outcomes
from 2010 before the conflict
in 2013 wherever they were at the time
so in order to think about whether camp
refugees are similar to other camp
refugees and control for those
differences
i'm first going to take this rich set of
baseline
variables that we have from 2010 and do
everything i can to flexibly control for
these to find out kind of the most
comparable group to refugees in camp
settings relative
to counterparts in urban settings in
both jordan
and kurdistan the second strategy i'm
going to use that i'm not going to talk
very much about today
i can if you're interested but i just
going to illustrate it here that gives
kind of
uh similar results so i'm going to use
the the multi-national nature of this
survey and compare
refugees in jordan with refugees in
lebanon where for political economy
reasons
lebanon never opened camps and so what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to take so the first
strategy is going to compare refugees
who are they move from syria to jordan
here
and think about different types of
refugees some who went to camps
and some who went to uh the towns
in jordan and then i'm gonna match them
based on their 2010 characteristics to
refugees because lebanon was closer who
went there instead
and so i'm going to look at the
difference between refugees who
are in camps in jordan relative to their
matched baseline uh counterparts who
went to lebanon instead
and look at this difference in outcomes
but of course the difference is there's
cross-country differences in lebanon
overall and so in order to net them out
i'm then going to control for the
differences based on refugees who i
predict
would have gone to urban areas had they
gone to jordan so controlling for these
cross-country differences
trying to again estimate the differences
uh and the effect of living in a camp
so that's going to exploit different
variation require different assumptions
and give me very similar estimates that
i'm going to
use to kind of bolster my confidence
that the the story that i'm telling
um is real in this setting
before we move on i've actually gotten
confused about what you're doing
and this is the maybe this is the
problem with the interdisciplinary
audience where sometimes you know
i imagine the picture might be helpful
for a lot of people and
for me like an equation might have been
more helpful
so could you could you just uh help us
understand okay or or maybe
say it in different words like in in the
form of estimating equations
what what the counter factor is sure so
the
the main strategy i'm talking about
today is going to be controlling for
selection
on observables and then talking about
what the unobservable selection
uh might have been looking only within
jordan comparing refugees who are in
camps
to refugees who are outside of camps
okay
then i've got this second strategy that
exploits different variation of refugees
who went to lebanon you and we have this
baseline
uh baseline characteristics and so
i'm then going to match them based on
their uh characteristics
before they were displaced and look at
this difference in differences
across lebanon and jordan based on
whether i predict they would go to camps
uh
and then look at that difference in
difference by whether they're actually
in camps or not
to estimate a treatment effect of being
in cans okay actually that helps a lot
thanks
and so when you say i'm looking at a
second strategy it's not a second
separate strategy you are combining the
two to create the different different
well so there are two different
strategies the results that i'm going to
present mostly today are going to just
be the
within within your name okay yeah so
okay yep i'm sorry thomas i have a
follow-up question
in addition to what mushi asked now i'm
interested to know
that 18 that you told us
choose between leaving incomes or not
where do they come from
in this divs in this approach where is
that 18 percent
so that's going to be the the first
difference in that approach is going to
be
kind of in living in camps living
outside of camps in jordan
and 100 in lebanon are living out got it
awesome okay and then uh thomas you used
the lang sometimes you were saying
controlling for observables sometimes
you're
saying matching so which of the two are
you doing like
flexible controls for observables or are
you actually doing some kind of formal
matching process
yeah so the the matching that i'm using
i'm creating a propensity score based on
their observable characteristics and
then matching on that propensity score
okay got it
so what do i so what what do i find kind
of
top level results here the i am
consistent with a lot of the criticism
of camps um
i'm going to find the camp residence
reduces income and in order to
standardize this i'm going to put this
in
per capita terms per month so the
wage penalty for living in a camp per
person is i'm estimating at 11
per person per month but the
the crucial story here is that they save
twenty two dollars per person per month
uh for rent and so that's a net at this
stage of eleven dollars per person per
month
then i'm going to look at these other uh
effects these other amenities and find
actually minimal differences at this
stage between
camp and urban uh residents
then i'm gonna estimate that services
and aid are more expensive in camps by
about nine dollars per person per month
although this estimate is
is quite rough but if you sum all this
up
that's going to be a net efficiency gain
from camps of about two dollars per
person per month
very roughly then if we think about a
wider picture here
urban refugees uh the main effect that
falls out from the
the other literature around urban
refugees in jordan is that
the rent has increased substantially for
jordanians we don't see much of an
effect
on uh wages or on income we don't see
much of an effect on crowd out from
uh public services but a massive
increase in rent
and so the the the background here to
what i'm going to be talking about is
that so after four years
think about overall camps and jordan are
efficiently subsidizing refugees who
again in quotes kind of opt out of the
urban
housing market and thinking about camps
as a
bringing additional housing at a time
when both
uh refugees and the host communities uh
very much need that
so i want to pause here and say that i'm
not kind of
saying that camps by any stretch of the
imagination are good places to live
most definitely not that's that's not at
all my argument
but i think what's important here is
that it actually may be a much more
depressing story in that
the life outside of camps may be
just as difficult uh for refugees
and so that just when we're thinking
about this
this potential just important to keep in
mind
so thomas i have a couple of
clarification questions here so
the first is um when you say cam
residence
reduces income or rent etc so that's all
relative to
uh if you could keep it on that slide
that would be helpful um
that's all relative to a syrian refugee
who happens to be located outside
account
correct correct yeah yep okay and
and then when you have the nine dollars
per person per month and services made
that's including the housing
like that's what we should be comparing
directly to the rent
number that you have right above it the
service and aid number that's
everything the government and that
non-profits put in externally
okay but but then
i mean that may not be the total social
cost of
housing somebody in a camp not it's not
just the external funds right but if
it's like
the government is providing some space
which has some opportunity cost right
that's not being valued in here
uh at this point exactly so in in jordan
uh these were this was just empty desert
that um yes you're exactly right it's
not value
uh when you when you say empty desert
you just mean to imply that that had
very low opportunity cost
indeed yeah okay okay and so you're
right that's not valued in here okay so
now then the question becomes like
something we should be grappling with
is like the empty desert like there may
be unobserved
differences in the quality of that
location right
um like how pleasant it is to live
in the empty desert that's far away from
other amenities etc
right that's probably welfare relevant
but we probably don't
have that being counted in the 22 versus
the nine
for sure okay okay so 22 might be you
know
so there's nothing there's nothing here
that suggests that's like meant to imply
that oh
you know camps are magically like
creating some efficiency gain by
uh by the government you know like
building a lot of housing together
that in a decentralized way the private
sector could not
provide it could be that this this
reflects quality differences but it
could also be that oh yeah
by building a camp there's huge
economies of scale and that's how
we're generating some efficiency exactly
i'm going to talk about that actually in
the
couple slides for now but yes i'm
talking about camps as a potential
coordinating device around like
what with a large group of people coming
in um
so yes that's one way to think about it
uh to follow up on that so
one of the camps is about uh 20 minutes
from the
next largest city so we're thinking
about kind of environmental differences
it's outside of the kind of urban area
but not that far outside another one is
much further
uh away but also then that's another
reason i
like the estimate of satisfaction that
respondents can price in something like
you know the heat of living in a desert
without any vegetation around and things
like that so
but yes totally agree uh the question
about how about coffee and water
trucking in and waste trucking out
that is included in these service uh
these service costs
these costs are from 2014 and i just
i'll talk more about this but those
costs have gone down
as the jordanian government has allowed
more kind of permanent
uh ish infrastructure to to be uh to be
constructed but that is
thomas also for example when you say
about
urban urban amenities are what are you
saying in terms of schools
and all that is that also measured
yes exactly so these costs include all
kinds of uh health care
education uh food and gas subsidies are
a huge cost in jordan as well as
electricity
and all that is priced in uh to the kind
of additional costs that refugees
are are imposing on either the
government or on donors uh so
it's a very rough estimate but it's uh
it's attempted
at least to be taken into account
hi thomas can i interrupt for one second
quickly
uh sorry do you hear me well actually
i'm calling from lebanon
so and and my my phd is about syrian
refugees in lebanon
so just to clarify maybe probably you're
doing it later on uh are you taking this
as a benchmark to compare
these figures the same figures forcing
refugees in lebanon
so that's what i do in the second
strategy that i won't uh
i could talk more about but um
i just yeah i just wanted to clarify
quickly because you know senior refugees
in lebanon um
you know we don't have camps here it's
called its's
and they actually do pay rent so i just
want to see if you're factoring this
later on
exactly and that's i think a relevant
counterfactual because
these refugees didn't have kind of you
know there weren't any camps in order to
move into so it's a
a very rough natural experiment what
exactly okay i'll wait i'll wait
sorry thanks no thank you
great okay and then so just a brief
overview of the literature this is part
of a
there's a report in the world bank that
summarized these data
um but it was never made public and
we're kind of seeing a growing
uh you know collection of data on
outcomes of displaced including
uh work by mushvik and paula for
the rohingya but i think uh so one thing
i'm doing here is that this is
extensive data bringing in attempts at
kind of
identification question around this
question that hasn't been
been discussed much and cost
effectiveness
then zooming back a little bit the
economics is talking more about going to
place specific effects whether that's
immigrant enclaves or in general
neighborhood effects
and i think it's important here to think
about this in terms of humanitarian
context and a place that is actually
created that the
the social planner has a choice of
whether to create or not
so i'm gonna uh then jump into the kind
of framework that i mentioned to mushvik
and then the setting data
down to the results and then conclude
with a policy discussion
so we think about kind of a big picture
of how people are allocated across space
and urban economists are thinking about
this in terms of the returns to scale
uh in that you get from positive kind of
conglomeration economies
in versus congestion costs we think
about traffic but especially rent
and so if we think about kind of there's
one existing city and a wave of forced
migrants
uh arrive if we just kind of let the the
market
allocate this on kind of the margin then
households
uh can choose either the city or the
desert based on their own kind of
private returns and there they'll kind
of be a benefit
uh to always kind of locating in the
city
but at some point there might be more
negative externalities for the marginal
person coming in
than the uh than the positive social
costs
uh and so if we think about
then they would allocate themselves all
into one city and this total welfare
uh would be positive but would
eventually start to
uh decline as urban economists have
noted that some cities seem to be
um like too large relative to
the costs and benefits if we think about
a social planner instead
that they could choose these city sizes
based on the total social welfare
you could have you could divide this
group into two
and double the uh social benefit where
it's positive and at some point with a
large enough population you have
the total social welfare exceeds uh
with two cities uh exceeds the kind of
like
marginal everyone deciding this for
themselves of
one city and so one potential way to
think about this is camps is acting as a
coordinating mechanism
uh for new new arrivals
to to locate
so i think many people are familiar with
the context um
syria it's more than half a million are
killed at this point the
uh conflict started in 2011 um
and now the largest host country is
turkey which we don't have any data for
the second largest host country is
lebanon i'm going to focus mostly on
jordan where there's about 600 000
refugees
and then talk a little bit about iraq
where there's 250 000 mostly syrian
kurdish refugees
uh as well as data that we have on
internally displaced people who came
from southern iraq
into the kurdistan region
in jordan at this point about 1 in 14
people is a syrian refugee and that was
the second highest total globally at
that point
at this point again they do not refugees
do not have access to the formal labor
market so if you're following the
jordan compact discussion uh that this
changed shortly after the survey
but important to keep in contact uh the
the institutions at the time which uh
refugees did not have any access to the
formal labor market
as i said before refugees are getting
direct assistance
uh both camp and urban residents in
terms of food vouchers in kind or in
terms of cash and i have data on all of
that
they're supposed to be getting free
education and some free health care
and for the most part that's happening
in the data although expenses are
slightly higher outside of camps
and then the other comparison between
limitations on movement is that camp
residents
they there's limitations in both camp
residents need a permit
to leave temporarily and so their
freedom of movement is most definitely
restricted
but urban residents in this context also
significantly worry about arrest over
uh having the right paperwork and also
expressed um
limitations on their movement in just
different ways
so in jordan there's two main camps this
is zaatri the largest one of 80 000
people
asrock is the second one with 30 000
people and i'll talk more about the
comparisons uh at the end
these are the populations in 2016 and
have basically stayed that way
um to the present day zatri was opened
in 2012
and at that point the jordanian
government required residents upon
arrival
but this became just very uh
unsustainable given the the
infrastructure at the time
about 200 000 refugees are estimated to
have been in the camps at some point and
moved to urban areas
um through either formal means there was
a bailout policy or an informal
um just leaving in the middle of the
night um
that was a major story kind of going on
and
responsible for a lot of the sorting
early in the
crisis percent of
employment in the camps is going to be
through nonprofit so this is going to be
an important thing to keep in mind we're
talking about
uh income for refugees especially in
camps
um and 80 of employment is inside the
camps
but i think about this uh employment
through non-profits as
uh comparable in many ways to public
services so these um you know they're
providing
some all kinds of different services
that nonprofits are providing and when
we think about 50
almost of the jordanian population is
working in the public sector
in some ways those are those are
analogous for the refugee population
the other thing to keep in mind here is
that at this time jordan was imposing
nothing permanent restrictions on the
camp store they couldn't build with
concrete they couldn't really invest in
the things like
water infrastructure waste management
that that was mentioned
uh earlier and so these are kind of like
lower bounds for what a camp uh could be
if there was uh more um
openness to making these a longer-term
investment
the data that i'm going to use i
collected in partnership with the world
bank unhcr and the danish aid
organization danita
uh in the first stage we randomly
selected areas and then stratified by
the percentage of syrians
and then in the second stage we randomly
selected households and then
uh selected a mix of hosts and syrians
in each one of these
small neighborhoods this is mostly going
to be representative for jordan it's not
quite representative it's only in
certain governorates and there was an
additional sample that we uh surveyed in
order to
bolster the uh the sample in amman uh
but it's going to include unregistered
refugees
and i'm mostly going to be using the the
sampling weights that we
uh that we calculated we had a response
rate above 85 percent
uh so i think we we have most uh mostly
attrition is not it's not much of a
worry i think we can call this mostly
representative and it's consistent with
other
uh surveys that have been done in jordan
as well i'm going to talk about some
labor market
migration and attitude questions as well
and this was done through we sampled two
15 to 64 year olds uh randomly
in each household and so it's not the
whole household that we have that for
and as before i said that we have the
the survey was done in 2016
and i'm gonna have outcomes we asked
them to recall from september 2010
before the conflict
and september 2013. so
first look at these data here uh again
as we've kind of said and as consistent
with a lot of the discussion urban
refugees in jordan earn much more so
in the capital city oman they're earning
almost 300 us dollars per household per
month
uh when we zoom in on just the two
governorates that are around the camps
mafrak and zarka that's
uh it's still more than in the camps but
it's uh
it's much less um difference between the
camps so about a hundred and ten dollars
relative to about eighty dollars uh per
household per month
uh for camps thomas i'm sorry to
interrupt you i wonder if you could give
us
i know this isn't shown here and maybe
the sample is not super large enough to
get into the details
but uh what do you know about the
distribution of household income across
these places
yeah so i'll talk a little bit about
that i mean so 40 of
households in camps are
40 of households outside of camps are
not
earning anything and sixty percent of
households
uh in camps are not earning anything so
it's sure
there's a large percentage that have no
earnings from either wage or
self-employment
um and so it's very kind of uh
yeah uh right skewed in in that sense
for sure
does that answer your question yeah and
a little bit a little bit different
across places too
it sounds like yes i mean the the
furthest right tail is definitely in
amman
but that's uh there's not that many
refugees earning
you know a substantial amount of money
got it okay thanks great
so then i'm going to add the red bar or
remittances and pensions and
any other income that's coming in that's
a very small proportion of the reported
income for refugees here and then the
assistance
again as i said it's uh similar across
locations in terms of how refugees
report the value of this
so it's the largest proportion in terms
of uh camps
camp residents but a substantial amount
for also refugees in the other
governorates around camps and also
i'm sorry thomas the type of a they
receive is it
similar do they receive perhaps
primarily food incomes and
something else like services outside of
camps or
how similar it is i think it's i think
it's fairly similar we don't have
we don't have we have data on whether
they receive food and
uh cash but not the amounts and then a
total amount
uh for the total value so i think
there's probably a little bit more
cash outside of camps than
than inside of camps or yes but uh
both refugees outside of camps and
inside of camps are receiving
food in kind food vouchers all kind of
same
uh same general uh
bundles of assistance right thanks as
far as
so now we look at the the rent
that refugees are paying um
we look at the governorates around camps
they're actually paying the middle uh
set of columns they're actually paying
more uh outside of camps in these
governorates
than they're earning so uh with
assistance on average they're
uh they still have gonna net positives
for other expenses but they're actually
paying more in rent
uh than their total earnings in camps
they're obviously not paying anything
and then in amman
this uh the total rent is almost as much
as they're earning
but a little bit less
a little bit larger difference for
residents in amon
so then the story that i'm going to be
telling is one about this this net
difference here so again kind of
subtract
zero from the the total income for camps
and then subtract out the the the rent
for the governor it's around camps and
you can see that this is
uh in camps there this is higher
uh for for these residents by not a
an enormous amount but a noticeable
amount in these just uh
raw data and so then um the next step is
going to be saying well what about kind
of
both observable and unobservable
differences that we want to think about
on
all of these dimensions
the last thing i'll just note here is
that
when we compare this to jordanians
the red dot here is the total household
income of jordanians we also have in the
survey you can see that they are earning
both in
these two other governments around the
camps and in amman
earning substantially more but the
average rent
that they're paying um is almost
identical
for jordanians and refugees in
um in urban areas so this kind of net
of expenses is much different for uh
jordanians
than it is for syrians in this sample
so now we want to think about whether
the goal that we have in mind here is to
estimate how
camp residents would have done outside
camps right is this net
uh kind of a real effect are these what
would the wage effects the wage penalty
of living in a camp
be if uh refugees lived uh if the camp
residents
live outside of camps so for the
economist i want to think about this is
like the treatment on the treated
estimate
right so not necessarily if you want to
match refugees who are in camps to the
most
similar people uh outside of camps to
get
just that counter factual and not the
kind of average treatment effect
and then you also want to think about
this as the partial equilibrium
so instead of camps closing completely
we want to think about this
uh first exercise as just one resident
is going to be leaving the camps um
and so that that marginal effect that
partial effect uh
but the but the camps still remain open
in terms of all the other kind of price
and and wage effects that
that could have and i'll come back to
this at the end
so the very simple uh classic identity
identifying assumption here is that
conditional on this rich set of
observables that we have
the choice to live in a camp is
independent of the potential
outcomes and specifically to the labor
market that i'm going to be measuring
um to start with and i'll go through
the selection process that i think makes
that potentially
uh plausible um and then again
kind of the the second identification
strategy gives me more confidence that
this is
in a reasonable
benchmark to go from here so i'm going
to have these
85 baseline covariates it's things about
the household demographics about
their housing characteristics in 2010
before displacement
uh 17 different assets their exposure to
violence
uh the amount of time that they've been
in jordan um
obviously things like that and then at
the individual level again for a subset
we have their 2010 uh outcomes on
employment status on occupations uh on
wages on their education levels
um all these kinds of things that feed
into this
um this estimation strategy
and so then the location choice is going
to be talking about both in terms of
estimating this effect of living in a
camp
but also i think it's just interesting
on its own that there's this perception
that the vulnerable the poor
more women and children are the ones who
go to camps
and i'm going to find some evidence for
that but not as kind of clear as i
origi as i had expected
so again consistent with the being kind
of the more
more vulnerable ex-ante uh who would
have moved and who would have stayed
in camps i'm gonna find that camp
residents have
uh few had fewer rooms in 2010 in their
house
they had less likely to have a water
heater uh less likely live in apartment
less like they have a tile floor
so everything here to the left of the
the red line the zero means that
uh camp residents were kind of less
likely to have these things
and so you're going to see this very uh
strong
prediction of the housing
characteristics
um based on whether refugees by 2016
are living in or outside of camps
and so i think that makes a lot of sense
when we think about kind of the the
housing characteristics and i'll go
through that more
but i then there also would have been
kind of other things that i would have
expected around
household size the number of dependents
um
that if this was um you know that could
have fed into this story and doesn't as
much as i would have expected
also refugees in camps so that could
have suggested
this is just a straight story of
negative selection the people who would
have had lower potential
uh earnings in the urban labor markets
are the ones who opt into camps and so a
lot of this difference
is explained just by these kind of
ex-ante characteristics
but there's other pieces of evidence in
the data that suggest that that's not
the only thing that's going on here so
refugees uh just on average were more
likely to have vehicles were more likely
to have televisions
who ended up living in a camp by 2016.
they were equally likely to uh kind of
say that they meet their basic needs
and the the two most predictive uh
elements in the data of whether you live
in a camp or not are just
how long you've lived in jordan uh so
urban residents have lived in jordan for
longer than camp residents
and whether you lived closer to the
border of jordan
uh before displacement
so as i say it's gonna i think a lot of
what's going on here is this just
willingness to live and what
the these caravans that they were
distributed
um and was kind of part of the the built
up environment in these camps and so
here's a a sense of what these look like
they're basically like these
uh these shipping containers um that the
refugees
uh were were given and so they started
out in these canvas tents until mid 2013
and then moved to these uh these
caravans
and i think that your just willingness
to live in in these caravans was what's
driving a lot of this sorting so
um i'm gonna have some evidence that the
more space
per person kind of you were allocated
upon your arrival to camps
the more likely you were to stay and
that's going to be just one of the main
driving factors much more than your kind
of potential labor market
outcomes or correlating with your 2010
labor market outcomes
that's really explaining a lot of this
story
so going along that we look at this
again these random samples of the
the males and females on their labor
market outcomes and we don't see a
significant difference in terms of
education
it's almost exactly the same in terms of
whether they were in school in 2010
we actually see it's not statistically
significant for males
but it is for females that males and
females were more likely to be
employed of those who moved uh and who
were
in camps by 2016 and
consistent with uh some more kind of on
an individual level
some kind of positive selection uh
refugees males who had jobs in 2010
camp residents were more likely to have
a higher isco score
for a kind of one to four level of uh
whether what skill level their job
required and so
overall this is not explaining a lot of
the variation and where refugees
uh are ending up by 2016
but it butts up against the story that
this is just uh
these are the the people who would have
been uh just
attained less in the labor market um
overall and so i think this is really a
story about kind of housing preferences
and what housing you were uh kind of
expecting and used to
much more than it is necessarily about
your potential labor market outcomes
that's also supported when we just ask
refugees why
they were moving and so um
out of the refugees who located from
camp
to urban areas the biggest one is
insecurity because at the beginning
of zatri being open there's no doubt
that there was a massive problem with
uh with insecurity and
just major problems that were eventually
kind of gotten under control by unhcr
so that's the number one uh reason that
the refugees report leaving
the second one is looking for a bigger
or better home
so uh i think this isn't important and
kind of
goes with the the other empirical data
presented
the uh when we're thinking about whether
this is driven by
labor market outcomes eight people said
this was work related but that's
much smaller than you know for instance
i was expecting
we similarly look at people who have
moved from urban to camps it's it's a
smaller number but the
largest uh besides insecurity in the
urban areas the largest
number that people report uh is that
rent was too high
again kind of consistent with housing
being a major uh factor for sorting
so now i'm going to move into i'm going
to take these estimates uh
this kind of story of selection and
these baseline
characteristics and i'm going to
put these into a generalized random
forest
which uh is an algorithm from susan
athey at all in 2018
that generates a propensity score around
the predictions of who's more likely
to live in a camp versus urban area
within jordan at the time of the survey
and so this algorithm is going to
flexibly capture
different interactions any kind of
higher orders
of the potential uh explanatory
variables here of who's
um locating in which area and
once you kind of tune this and take into
account all these different variables
it's with 81 accuracy uh
able to predict um who's
where refugees are going to be living at
the time
of uh of the survey so i think this um
this does a fairly good job of capturing
the the selection story here and then
again the main
uh factors that fall out are that the uh
arrival month is the most predictive
element of where refugees are going to
live
followed by their housing
characteristics and their
origin origin governance
for where they end up living
then i'm going to take this propensity
score and i'm going to use this to
balance across 2010 characteristics
so i'm gonna use the uh indians and
ruben method
to instead of matching kind of one for
one
uh directly refugees in and out of camps
i'm going to stratify
and create different blocks of refugees
that are
mostly similar within that propensity
score
uh and then i'm just going to follow the
algorithm that indians and ruben have
have laid out in order to create this um
this blocking estimate that gives me
this um
uh treatment on the treated estimate of
how much uh to estimate this effect of
how refugees
would have done outside of camps and
then i'm going to present the results
from
ordinary least squares and from other
methods uh in order to just
uh look at the the straight selection uh
with just a linear specification
and whenever i do that i'm going to
control for the head of households age
age squared their gender their 2010
education
the months they were displaced uh fixed
effects for the origin governorate
and then the linearized propensity score
that i estimate from this
in order to capture just those selection
characteristics
and then i'm going to present two
different estimates
so one is with uh without governor at
fixed effects and this is going to then
uh basically estimate the effect of
living in a camp
relative to uh ever the average
of all potential destinations outside of
the camp and this is specifically
in in this case going to take into
account uh amman
where refugees you know could have gone
up ended up had they left the camp
and then i'm going to present another
specification
that estimates um within
government so just comparing essentially
refugees who are living
uh in moffrock with refugees who live in
the
camp zachary next door and refugees who
live in zarka
relative to uh the
uh the camps who live the the refugees
who live in
asrock and the governor
okay so now i'm gonna get on to the
results
unless there are any questions
yeah thomas i did have a couple of quick
questions could you go
maybe back two slides yep
this slide yeah perfect thanks uh
one question is um how are you thinking
about origin
um as being a predictor is that are you
thinking maybe they have
existing networks in jordan or something
like that yes exactly
so almost half of the refugees in jordan
are from the dura
governorate which is the southernmost
governor in syria
the borders jordan um and so the
the further that you came to jordan the
less likely you are
to live in a camp and i think those
people you know probably had
other people that they were looking to
meet uh in in jordan already and
things like that got it and then the
other thing
uh you know but maybe put me off if you
like could you just talk me through how
to
think about the combination of the
propensity score and the ols so
like could you you know i'm thinking of
kind of typical propensity score
uh measures you know you just you would
do some kind of matching based on the
propensity score and then here you're
throwing it the propensity score into
uh i know less regression with some
other co-variants that maybe were
already a part of the propensity score
how should i be
interpreting that or thinking about it
yeah exactly a great question
so the the the algorithm recommended by
indians and rubin is to create these
blocks so basically i'm gonna have like
six
blocks that within each one of those
blocks i'm going to
then run the ols that controls for these
kind of main characteristics that i
chose
ad hoc in order to
to net out those effects and then that
creates a treatment effect within each
one of these blocks and then you weight
the blocks by the the number within the
blocks and by
those estimates um and then i'm just
going to have a straight just ols
specification with everybody as well
so there's two different things one is
kind of within the ols
and within the the stratification and
then another one is
just ols with the the linearized
propensity score
and the other um explanatory variables
okay thanks great
okay so the first outcome that i'm going
to look at is that camps
uh reduce household earning and this
outcome is going to be a total of the
wage and self-employment income
uh that was 30 days prior to the time of
the survey
and so i'm going to look at this in just
the um
the absolute measure in terms of usd on
the the left here and then
take the inverse hyperbolic uh sign in
order to account for these many zeros
again 60 percent of households uh don't
have any earnings from this wage and
self-employment income
and uh in camps and forty percent don't
have any earnings
uh in urban areas and so it's important
that if we uh just took the log we
wouldn't be able to con
include these households with zero
and so this is going to give me uh these
overall household level effects
um and so you can see with without
governor fix fixo compared to
everybody uh all the urban
residents i'm going to estimate in
effect i think of 67
here that's statistically significant
when i move to just estimating to
refugees within the nearest governance
it's still going to be a negative effect
for camps on earnings but it's actually
not statistically significant
and i find basically the same thing when
i um transform the
variable to the inverse hyperbox
this is that same thing in regression
form so that's the
from these blocks again i've got kind of
six blocks here that i put all together
that gives me this 67 effect off of
um an urban mean of 192.
and so that's the kind of first
specification it's very similar when i
uh don't worry about this blocking
estimate and just
pull everything into the same regression
and this is going to give me 63
wage penalty for living in a camp and
then
the oster delta for whether the
unobservables could potentially
overturn these results is above one uh
which means that we wouldn't
we would expect that selection is doing
uh on observables is doing a fairly good
job here and that unobservables wouldn't
overturn
this result so these results are driven
largely by lower male employment uh 45
uh male employment in urban regions
relative to
32 percent uh for camp uh
residents and so that's where the
majority
of the the earnings penalty
is coming from for living in a camp uh
in this setting
i was also surprised to see there's
actually a positive effect for
females uh for female employment so
uh it is in this case there's nine
percent
uh employment for women in camps versus
two percent
outside of camps and i think and most of
what's going on here 86
of the employment uh for women in camps
is through non-profits
uh basically looking to you know have
kind of equitable access to these jobs
and so that's a substantial i think
important story but it's not enough to
kind of compensate for the overall
household earnings
so then i'm going to move into
calculating this net income
per capita and that's going to take
these earnings so from self-employment
from um uh from wage employment and i'm
going to add the other income
i'm going to add assistance then i'm
subtract out a
conservative estimate of the minimum
expenses that
refugees might have faced outside of a
camp
and so in order to calculate that i'm
going to take the
10th percentile of rent within the
governorates that
refugees outside of cancer pain so i'm
going to standardize
the expenses in camps to zero and then
subtract out the minimum expenses that
refugees
are paying in urban areas but take a
very conservative estimate
of that they're also paying more outside
of camps for school
and for health costs uh and i'm not even
going to factor those into account again
to give kind of a very
conservative estimate of how much is
being saved
uh from living in a camp another
kind of outcome we think about or to in
order to benchmark these effects are
food prices but the median food prices
reported inside and outside camps
are uh identical in this setting and
then i'm going to convert this to per
capita estimates
uh in order to standardize with the cost
estimates that i have
so when i just look at the total income
per capita here first i still get this
negative effect
uh about ten dollars per person
uh per month of living in a camp
but when i subtract out these um
net these minimum expenses this is when
i get kind of the overall positive
effect
of net expenses of living in a camp and
because
there's kind of a different expense
subtracted out for
different governorates i'm going to get
a similar coefficient a similar effect
whether
you compare them to everybody including
those living in amman
or to the refugees who are living in the
most kind of similar areas
of about 11 uh per
person per month net for camp residents
some additional evidence that i have
here is that
um in order to
so refugees inside of camps are much
less
in debt than refugees outside of camps
and the story that i think explains this
best is that refugees
outside of camps are having to go into
more debt
uh in order to afford uh their larger
housing costs so
these estimates are very large uh about
80 percent
of refugees in the urban settings uh
who express a debt of at least 100 dinar
which is 140 us dollars
and that's 20 percentage points less in
the urban area and for refugees who are
living in camps
uh with i'm also not seeing any
difference in access to credit
um and so that that wouldn't explain
this either i am
then if you ask just from the subjective
measure of whether refugees consider
their household to be poor or not um
it's
uh actually lower that fewer refugees
consider themselves poor
uh in camps than outside of camps this
isn't statistically significant but i
think also kind of illustrative
that the financial situation for
refugees uh
outside of camps may be much worse 84
here than i think we kind of have in
mind
we want to think about urban refugee
situations
so i should note also here that there's
fewer assets for refugees who are
in in camps in terms of tvs radios and
appliances i think this has uh
changed this is increasing over time uh
and so converging in in some sense but
it's not that uh you know it's it's an
important difference that's
um also should be noted we're thinking
about kind of this total
total effects here
so again a major concern about uh
refugees over the the long run and
living in camps is um you know how these
effects
are going to evolve and so what i do for
this again
refugees on average have only been in
these camps about
uh two and a half years but i'm going to
look at those refugees who
were in the camps when we asked about
september 2013
uh and i'm going to look at their
employment outcomes at that point
relative to their outcomes when we
surveyed them in the spring of 2016.
and so if you kind of think about the
parallel trends that if you assume that
they would have been on parallel trends
if
not for living on camps then you can
interpret this
uh as as kind of the the difference of
camps
and so you'll see here that while the
employment is lower for males
in camps they're on a similar trend
increase over this time period wage
growth is a little bit
higher for refugees
outside of camps but growing also for
refugees
inside of camps and then i've also gone
back to the 2018 survey so two years
later
and this employment has basically
converged between refugees
uh outside of camps and inside of camps
so 46
employment uh outside of camps but up to
44
uh inside of camps and so it seems like
the refugees are actually on even a
faster
employment growth at least within camps
by 2018.
when we look at women it's important to
note that they started off
higher uh employment percentage and so
there might be some
uh kind of selection bias going on here
but that this is also a substantially
larger wage growth
again i think mostly attributed to
non-profits
but it also persists into 2018 this 8
percentage points versus three
percentage points by 2018
just not enough really to estimate kind
of wage uh
wage effects here and any differences
but i think this again it doesn't
provide evidence much evidence that
refugees in camps are stagnating much
more than refugees
outside of camps that i is just an
important thing to
kind of keep in mind and to continue to
you know survey these populations and to
monitor as we think about
uh the long run aspects
then we want to think about amenities
and services
so i'm going to find actually that
primary school-aged children
in camps are more likely to be in school
by two
in 2016 and so it's not
it's not a lot but here at very
much younger ages we see that they are
more likely to be in in school and this
drops off for
both camp and urban refugees as we get
into secondary schooling unfortunately
here
um but not substantial evidence that
children in
uh camp schools are at least attending
much less
does school attendance differ sorry to
interrupt do school attendance differ by
gender
no not that i not that i was picking up
here
and do you have a good explanation for
why attendance for five years old is so
low in urban areas i
i don't have much of a sense i think
that um
one guess could be that urban households
were waiting a little bit to
because there are some school fees
associated in urban areas whether those
are formal or informal
but they're just like delaying a little
bit
would be one explanation and also like
efforts within the camp
uh in order to get more kind of school
children in school
maybe because there are not enough
preschools as well
or the age the legal age for entering
school
is set around six probably or something
like that
yeah um i don't have don't have a great
uh great sense but it at least doesn't
suggest that they're doing much worse in
camps than outside
sorry thomas i have one more question
about the schools uh i just want to
compare them to lebanon
are they mixed shifts or one shift
combining jordanian and syrian together
because this is an issue
that we're facing here in lebanon yes so
i'm sorry if i uh i didn't finish yet
plus the curriculum actually
that was actually an issue this is why
the syrian curriculum in teaching
hoping for the kids to return back home
is different than the lebanese one
so there was also another issue i just
just wondering if this is the same case
in jordan
yes so jordan also opened the two shifts
in high prevalence areas uh so i
actually have another program
another project that uh
demonstrates how this uh basically
jordanian students were not
uh very exposed to syrian students that
the prevalence of syrians in these
schools was
uh was pretty low and syrians were
mostly in this kind of second shift
of education so it's very similar
um in the jordanian context as well
thanks
uh and so then public services people
are less satisfied in camps
but overall people feel report feeling
very safe
um safe or very safe
both inside and outside camps
and just one more point here is that
women in camps list a lot more regular
contacts than urban women
uh one thing i noticed when i was uh
kind of doing part of this survey was
women who were in urban areas expressing
uh
loneliness and isolation from not having
the kind of same networks that
um and being afraid to to leave and be
able to
find uh kind of um build a a community
like
refugees in camtas and that's also borne
out in the data
so just a quick clarifying question you
mentioned earlier that
concerns about safety we're a major
driver of
um choosing living in a camp versus
urban areas but then you find that
actually everyone feels safe regardless
of where they end up living
is that right okay that's that's
definitely a function of at the
beginning
these camps were very insecure and the
government unhcr has done a lot to
security over time so that's a just
evolution
got it thanks sorry thomas can i
interrupt uh
sorry go ahead no go ahead i was going
to move to the next thing so
no just yeah just regarding probably
we're back paddling a little bit
uh regarding the ethnographic studies
when you were mentioning the employment
for women did you also consider
that some woman because this is the case
i'm facing when i'm doing my
when i finish my ethnographic studies
the results that came from that
that most of them who are employed
are usually either widowed or their
husband
you know is jailed or got lost during
the war
so i'm not sure if you factor in this
variable to justify the implement of
women
increasing that's interesting i
will i'll look at that i would suspect
that there's some of that going on
again my main explanation here there's
very little
uh women employment in
urban areas at all and so not really
enough to be able to
tease out whether it's a male or female
headed household but within
camps i can look at that a little bit
we do have their household demographics
from 2010 so
uh let me get back to you on that again
most of this story i think is really the
opportunity provided by nonprofits in
the camps
uh but that still within that employment
might be the story that you have in mind
okay thank you so again kind of going to
paul's question one question yeah there
is a question there on the
chat about the if male headed
households are more likely to be in
urban areas than female-headed
female-headed households are a little
bit more likely to be
in um in camps than outside of camps but
not
um substantially it's it's not a a major
predictor of who's going to locate in
which area
thanks so we're talking about kind of
the evolution over time here
this is the the cantrell ladder so
asking people to recall that has all
kinds of problems but i think it's still
a useful exercise
where high here is my life could not be
any better
and one here is my life could not be any
worse and so consistent with
there being a uh the
camps improving over time we see on
these blue lines here these are people
who were in
zaatari in 2013 um
they the the conflict started
satisfaction goes way down
many of these stayed in syria for the
initial parts of the conflict and then
the camp is is a really rough place to
be at this time and we see kind of
steady improvement to the point by the
time the survey that we see no
differences between
zaatari and urban areas we see a similar
kind of
u-shaped trend here in azeroth but
azeroth is still
people report substantially lower
satisfaction in azeroth
and i think that's because it's more
isolated it's hotter it's a just worse
place to be and i'll talk about that
at the end i don't see any differences
on the
employment uh income effects
that i've talked about earlier and so i
cooled those together but on the
satisfaction
uh differences most definitely emerge
here
when i moved to kurdistan here there is
a very very different setting refugees
had access to work they had freedom of
movement to leave the camps completely
and so i think this is just a better
model from especially like a human
rights perspective
um and just a better
model overall they see similar effects
in terms of
um the potential the camp wage penalty
so a substantial wage penalty
from living in a camp that refugees earn
much less but when i subtract out the
minimum expenses in the same way that i
did for jordan
you see this positive effect here the
blue for jordan this is basically a zero
in camp so this wage penalty is
uh is basically netted out by the rent
that
um camped refugees um
save in the kurdistan region
so now the last couple slides here so
cost effectiveness
so there's not many estimates of
the cost across locations i'm trying to
pull the
two main ones that do this in 2014 was
the best i could find
but the non-profits uh through the
syrian response plan estimate
uh that it's about sixty dollars per
person per month more expensive to serve
refugees
uh in camps than it is outside of camps
i'm going to take this estimate
then i'm going to look at this usaid
study on the fiscal effects
from 2014 and this is going to provide
the estimates from the government
expenditures
so how much the whatever is going
through the jordanian government
in terms of education health electricity
subsidies
uh municipal services food and gas
subsidies
and this is net of the regional response
plan so the gross budget support that's
going on here
and that's uh for the government it's 51
dollars per person more expensive
to um to to serve refugees
outside of camps so overall that's a
nine dollar difference plus the 11
difference that i'm estimating here
again is a very rough estimate of about
two dollars
now we think about the general
equilibrium so think about the thought
experiment
of that jordan has never opened camps
and they host the same number of
refugees
so this would represent a 22 percent
increase in
the urban refugee population um
that then we think about the effects on
refugees and on the host communities
so for refugees potentially there would
be crowd out of each other from
housing and from jobs and that would
mean that these current estimates
actually understate
uh the camp surplus that i'm estimating
here
but for jordanians like i said earlier
the
main effects are not from income are not
from public services in terms of
education
or from access to health care that uh
syrians are crowding jordanians are
having a negative effect on
it's the cost of living and so that
there's very inelastic supply of housing
and so there's two different papers that
estimate large increases
from syrians uh who locate close to
jordanians
having a substantial negative effect on
um on the jordanians in that area
and so if we think about again refugee
camps as providing this additional
housing would alleviate some of that
burden i think that's a very important
kind of
factor to build in here when we're
thinking about the overall
net of of camps and what camps could be
the other thing i'll say quickly is that
if camps close you can think about the
aid budget potentially being effective
so
one jordanian official said to me that
the
one of the arguments for opening a camp
was simply because they quote learned
their lesson with palestinians that the
aid money
uh they suspected was much less because
they allowed people to assimilate
and so with syrians they wanted to keep
them visible in order to keep the aid
money flowing and i'm actually going to
be looking at this in another project
forthcoming so my final slide here
is uh just kind of what what are we what
should we take away from this estimate
uh from from this discussion and so i
think about this as
uh zatri and kurdistan as being uh kind
of the lower bounds of what
camps and i put that in quotation marks
as like suburbs or enclaves
uh could be for a humanitarian response
so
thinking about making these areas
attractive for refugees that could be
a win-win but that i think these uh this
environment shows the design and the
context are key
so that it's possible
that returns to in-kind shelter are even
higher than the cash equivalent when we
kind of factor everything
uh in here overall again owing to the
fact that the housing supply
is so inelastic in the short run and the
builders are going to find it risky
uh to invest in this population that
they don't know exactly how long they're
going to be staying
refugees want to go home host
communities want them to go home
and so the housing market might not
immediately respond with like standard
housing
uh in order to house a refugee
population and that shelter here is just
going to be a key constraint for both
refugees
and for hosts but providing that shelter
does not have to imply the other
restrictions
we often associate with camps these
camps don't need to be isolated in the
same ways that we see in in the
jordanian context in other contexts
you don't need to impose limits on
movement uh
or these restrictions on on permanent
building
those are likely lose-lose situations so
we see from the examples in asrock
relative to zaatri that fewer refugees
are going to stay in
more isolated in worse areas they're
going to be higher costs for non-profits
to
engage in the like water trucking and
waste management
in more remote areas and so these are
just
lose-lose whereas if we could
incentivize camp residents
uh or suburban residents we want to call
it that to minimize kind of
citizen crowd out and reduce
expenditures on refugees
i think there's a better model in here
somewhere than just kind of pretending
that refugees
in urban areas are going to be doing
better uh
just overall and so we also want to
think about the kind of counterfactual
labor market and housing markets that
matter here
um that those are going to be you know
they're weak in this context in the
jordanian context whereas we think about
this you know in europe
uh that might be totally different and
we want to kind of reevaluate this
overall
um but uh just important to kind of keep
in mind we're thinking about
generalizability and then as well as
kind of following the long run
outcome to totally acknowledge that
these uh kind of
outcomes of policy are very uncertain
and just
kind of call for for more research in
this area to
to keep this discussion open around kind
of what what arrangements could be
better for both kind of host communities
and refugees
so i will leave it there thank you so
much for
uh for having me in for the questions
and i'm happy to stick around uh
with anyone that wants to chat more so
thanks again